wenn es um Einwanderung Flucht und Asyl
geht haben die Debatten darüber oft auch
sehr hässliche Seiten nicht nur bei
unangenehmen Familienfeiern sondern vor
allem wenn man in die Social Media
Kommentarspalten schaut ein bestimmtes
narrativ findet man immer wieder die
verschwörungserzählung vom großen
Austausch das kommt aber nicht nur von
anonymen Trollen auf Facebook auch der
reichste Mensch der Welt Elon Musk
kommentiert liked und retweetet
regelmäßig Posts die an die Erzählung
anknüpfen musks Beiträge auf seiner
Plattform Ex früher mal Twitter werden
von Millionen Menschen gelesen mit
solchen takes schafft es immer wieder in
die Medien und sorgt so auch für die
Verbreitung der Erzählung manchen ist
sie vielleicht auch eher als
Bevölkerungsaustausch oder umfolkung
bekannt ein Begriff der mittlerweile
auch innerhalb der AFD weit verbreitet
ist ich halte den Begriff umfolgung
nicht für rechtsextrem der
Verfassungsschutz sieht es allerdings
anders als AFD Bundessprecher Tino
krupaller er bezeichnet Begriff sogar
als direkte Referenz auf das Vokabular
der Nazis immer wieder werden von
Mitgliedern der AFD Anspielung auf den
großen Austausch verbreitet z.B von
Björn höcke dem AFD Landeschef in
Thüringen dahinter steckt viel
politische Strategie und das kann
gefährlich werden auch weil die
Erzählung schon bis in den Bundestag
geschwappt ist ebenso konsequent gegen
ihre ersetzungsmigration den großen
Austausch der von der UN und anderen
Regierungsorgan aufwendig beworbene
Bevölkerungsaustausch sie haben der
umfolkung umfolkung Deutschland Tür
undor geöffnet deshalb analysieren wir
in diesem Video was genau in dem
narrativ drin steckt wo es her kommt und
wo die Gefahren
liegen der große Austausch ist eine
verschwörungserzählung aus der extremen
Rechten sie spielt in deren Strategie
eine zentrale Rolle in Europa wird die
Erzählung unter anderem von der
identitären Bewegung gepusht das ist
eine europaweit aktive Organisation von
Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten die vom
Verfassungsschutz als gesichert
rechtsextrem eingestuft wird um das
narrativ vom großen Austausch zu
verstehen haben wir uns in die Weltsicht
von extrem rechten eingearbeitet ihre
Reden gehört und ihre Bücher gelesen
zwei rechtsextreme Autoren haben uns
besonders genau angeschaut einmal den
Franzosen Renault cu der den Begriff vom
großen Austausch 2011 geprägt hat er
gilt als Vordenker der rechtsextrem
Partei rassemblement national aus
Frankreich vielleicht kennt ihr sie eher
noch unter ihrem alten Namen Front
National in der deutschen Öffentlichkeit
stand lange ein anderer Autor im
randenlicht Akif perinche hat früher
Romane über Katzen geschrieben ja
wirklich kein Witz später ist er auf
rechtspopulistische Sachbücher
umgestiegen als Skandalautor war auch
schon öfters in den Medien zu sehen 2016
wurde sein Buch umfolkung wie die
Deutschen still und leise ausgetauscht
werden veröffentlicht mit dem er die
Erzählung vom großen Austausch
verbreitet hat die beiden Autoren sind
prägend für die verschwörungserzählung
deshalb haben wir versucht mit ihren
Texten eine Art Definition davon zu
entwickeln auch wenn es bei einem so
abstrakten Thema natürlich nicht immer
ganz leicht ist erstmal die Basics die
verschwörungserzählung vom großen
Austausch behauptet dass das
einheimische das autochtone Volk in
Deutschland und Europa ausgetauscht wird
und zwar durch Menschen deren Kultur
nicht hierher passen soll autochton ist
ein Begriff aus der Ethnologie und heißt
im Prinzip eingeboren das Wort wird im
Zusammenhang mit der Erzählung ziemlich
oft verwendet und gibt dir dadurch einen
vermeintlich wissenschaftlichen Touch
dieser angebliche große Austausch hat
zwei Säulen die erste ist Migration
fremde Menschen kommen in die westliche
Welt und sind irgendwann in der Überzahl
das haupten zumindest die Leute die die
Erzählung Teilen beim früheren AFD
Fraktionschef Alexander gauland klang
das 2016 dann so es ist liebe Freunde
eine Politik der menschlichen
Überflutung es ist der Versuch das
deutsche Volk allmehlich zu ersetzen
durch eine aus allen Teilen dieser Erde
herbeigekommene Bevölkerung die zweite
Säule der Erzählung sind Geburtenraten
demnach bekommen die Einheimischen zu
wenig Kinder die Fremden zu viele so
sollen die ursprünglichen Völker dann
irgendwann aussterben das alles soll von
einer mächtigen Elite gesteuert werden
und warum die einsagen aus purem Hass um
das deutsche Volk zu vernichten andere
sagen um die Macht der Elite dauerhaft
zu sichern aber wie soll das
funktionieren einige behaupten da wo
viele Menschen einwandern und sich
fortpflanzen würden leichter
kontrollierbare Völker entstehen das
wird wiederum ganz unterschiedlich
begründet auf der einen Seite z.B mit
einem angeblich niedrigeren IQ von
muslimischen Migrantinnen und Migranten
auf der anderen Seite redet kamü z.B
davon dass Menschen die entwurzelt
wurden leichter steuerbar sind dadurch
dass sie sich nicht mehr mit ihrer
Heimat und Kultur identifizieren können
verlieren sie angeblich ihre Identität
und damit auch ihre Selbstständigkeit
und sind dadurch leichter zu
kontrollieren also zumindest in kamüs
Vorstellung diese Menschen sollen dann
von den Eliten nach Belieben eingesetzt
werden können z.B für den eigenen Profit
wer genau diese Eliten sein sollen und
warum sie so einen Austausch angeblich
planen auch da gibt's unter den
Anhängerinnen und Anhängern der
Erzählung unterschiedliche Ideen auf die
schauen wir später im Video die
Begründung beim Thema Migration fußt auf
etwas was die Wissenschaft als
kulturellen Rassismus bezeichnet aber
was ist damit genau gemeint Björn höcke
sagt z.B öffentlich in einem Tweet dass
bestimmte Kulturen nicht vermischt
werden sollten in der Erzählung vom
großen Austausch geht es immer wieder
darum dass eingewanderte und geflüchtete
aus vor allem muslimisch geprägten
Ländern angeblich nicht nach Deutschland
passen würden und zwar wegen ihrer
Kultur oft wird dabei kein Unterschied
gemacht zwischen Menschen die nach
Deutschland gekommen sind und Menschen
die sogar in Deutschland geboren und
aufgewachsen sind aber ein
Migrationshintergrund haben das nennen
die Sozialwissenschaften dann
kulturellen Rassismus oder auch
Rassismus ohne Rassen anders als beim
klassischen rassismus wird da nicht in
erster Linie mit biologischen Merkmalen
wie z.B der Hautfarbe argumentiert beim
kulturellen Rassismus geht's um
Lebensgewohnheiten und Tradition die
werden als Argumente benutzt um Menschen
in Schubladen zu stecken es wird
behauptet dass etwas wie Tradition so
tief in den Leuten drin steckt dass sich
Menschen aus unterschiedlichen Kulturen
nie wirklich aneinander anpassen können
bei den Vordenker der
verschwörungserzählung klingt diese Art
von Rassismus so dennoch überwiegt in
der Nachbetrachtung gesamtheitlich die
muslimisch-arabische Destruktivität
Bevölkerung mit Islam im Hirn können nur
autoritär regiert und unter Kontrolle
gehalten werden jeder weiß doch dass die
dümmsten Menschen des Planeten in Afrika
Arabien und in den islamländern Asiens
zu Hause sind ren äußert sich ebenfalls
deutlich zur Vermischung von Kulturen es
ist kriminell das Zusammenleben von
Völkern zu erzwingen die einander
verabscheuen das was kamyder sagt heißt
bei vielen rechtsextremen auch
ethnopluralismus das ist eine Idee die
schon seit vielen Jahrzehnten gibt damit
ist gemeint verschiedene Völker dürfen
existieren aber salopkeesagt nur da wo
sie herkommen sie sollen sich nicht
vermischen daraus leitet sich dann auch
die Forderung nach sogenannter
Remigration ab Menschen die angeblich
nicht deutsch genug sind sollen zurück
in ihre Herkunftsländer gebracht werden
dazu muss man sagen es geht nicht um
deutsches Aufenthaltsrecht diese
Forderung wird unabhängig davon erhoben
Björn höcke wünschte sich z.B schon 2018
in seinem Buch ein großangelegtes
remigrationsprojekt um das an der Stelle
noch mal genauer einzuordnen
ethnopluralismus ist ein Begriff um
Rassismus zu verschleiern im Gegensatz
zum biologischen rassismus wird nicht
mehr konsequent behauptet dass
unterschiedliche Völker besser oder
schlechter sind sondern vor allem dass
sie sich durch eine Vermischung der
Kulturen gegenseitig Schwächen würden
dazu muss man sagen bei dieser Idee wird
komplett ignoriert dass sich Kulturen
schon immer gegenseitig beeinflusst und
geprägt haben um das alles noch besser
zu verstehen muss man sich außerdem den
historischen Ursprung Anschauen der geht
zurück bis ins 19 und das früher 20
Jahrhundert damals sind die
Rassentheorien entstanden die Menschen
in verschiedene Rassen eingeteilt haben
in manche die angeblich zivilisiert und
leistungsfähig sind und andere die dazu
nicht in der Lage sein sollen die sollen
demnach weniger wert sein se mehr noch
laut dieser Theorie sind die sogar
gefährlich und zwar weil sie sich
angeblich wie Parasiten an den
Hochkulturen festbeißen würden und sie
irgendwann von innen zerstören der
Gedanke war vor allem im
Nationalsozialismus weit verbreitet das
hat z.B auch Alfred Rosenberg
geschrieben der oft als Chefideologe der
NSDAP bezeichnet wird er hat daran
gearbeitet diese Ideologie in die
Bevölkerung zu tragen die Rassentheorie
und ihre weitläufige Verbreitung waren
dann auch die Grundlage für die Rassen
Sätze der Nazis Stichwort Aria Rosenberg
war während der nazierrschaft unter
anderem für den sogenannten Generalplan
Ost zuständig dabei wurden 3 Millionen
polnische Jüdinnen und Juden deportiert
und ermordet 780.000 nichtjüdische
Menschen wurden aus ihren Wohnorten im
besetzten Polen vertrieben in diesen
Gebieten wurden dann deutsche
angesiedelt die Nazis nannten das dann
Germanisierung oder auch umfolkung das
Wort umfolkung hat seinen Ursprung also
in nazokabular aber nicht nur der
rassistische Anteil sondern auch die
zweite wichtige Komponente des großen
Austausches der Fokus auf Geburtenraten
war während des Nationalsozialismus ein
großes Thema und sogar noch früher schon
nach dem ersten Weltkrieg hat
beispielsweise der Philosoph Oswald
Spengler von sinkenden Geburtenraten und
von einem rassenselbstmord gesprochen
andere haben das auch Volkstod genannt
den Begriff benutzen rechtsextreme heute
noch dazu hat Spengler dann 1918 das
Buch der Untergang des Abendlandes
veröffentlicht kommt euch das vielleicht
ein bisschen bekannt vor ganz ähnlich
klingt nämlich auch ein anderer sehr
bekannter Buchtitel und zwar der des
ehemaligen SPD Politikers Tilo Sarazin
2010 hat der mit seinem Buch deutschland
schafft sich ab für große Diskussionen
gesorgt im Buch begründet er angebliche
Probleme in der Gesellschaft unter
anderem damit dass deutsche Akademikerin
zu wenig Kinder bekommen auch die die
heute vom großen Austausch sprechen
geben Emanzipation und damit auch
Feminismus und Gleichstellung die Schuld
Geburtenrückgänge lassen sich zum Teil
auch durch solche umente erklären
Gleichstellung und der bessere Zugang
von Frauen zum Arbeitsmarkt spielen eine
Rolle aber z.B auch Verhütungsmittel und
die Aufklärung darüber Frauen haben ein
Entscheidungsrecht beim Kinderkriegen
und dürfen sich auch bewusst dagegen
entscheiden beim großen Austausch wird
im gleichen Atemzug auch immer wieder
von einer überdurchschnittlichen
Fruchtbarkeit von Menschen aus
muslimisch geprägten Ländern gesprochen
das hat Sarazin übrigens auch behauptet
obwohl der kein klarer Vertreter der
verschwörungserzählung ist hat er Thesen
geprägt die in das narrativ Aufgen
wurden angeblich würden Muslime zu viele
Kinder bekommen die deutschen dadurch
verdrängen und langfristig für einen
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
Abschwung Sorgen da sind wir übrigens
wieder beim kulturellen Rassismus
Sarazin hat davon gesprochen dass
Muslime weniger leistungsfähig und
weniger leistungsbereit sein und auch
Renault kamu und akiv perinciüberhaupten
sowas dazu muss man sagen in der
Realität ist es so dass selbst bei
Menschen mit Wurzeln in mehrheitlich
muslimisch geprägten Ländern die
durchschnittliche Geburtenrate konstant
sinkt an der Stelle ist also ganz
wichtig zu betonen dass das keine reine
Sache von Herkunft oder Religion ist
sondern vor allem von den
sozioökonomischen Bedingungen im Land
dort wo die Lebensstandards oder das
Bildungsniveau hoch sind sind die
Geburtenraten tendenziell auch niedriger
so jetzt haben wir uns die zwei großen
Säulen auf die sich die Legende vom
großen Austausch stützt sehr genau
angeschaut Behauptung zur Migration auf
der einen Seite und Behauptung zu
Geburtenraten auf der anderen aber wir
erinnern uns ein Punkt bleibt noch übrig
der große Austausch soll ja angeblich
aktiv gesteuert werden von angeblichen
Eliten die als konkrete Feindbilder
aufgebaut werden renaamu das ist der der
den Begriff großer Austausch erfunden
hat macht alle regierenden Parteien der
letzten Jahrzehnte für den Austausch
verantwortlich auch auf dem AFD
Parteitag zur Aufstellung der Liste für
die Europawahl 204 gab es ähnliche
Aussagen zu hören was uns aber dann
irgendwann fehlt das ist unser Volk und
dieses wird von Berlin und Brüssel der
Auflösung preisgegeben aber was wir
wirklich fürchten müssen das ist ist
nicht der menschengemachte Klimawandel
nein wir sollten uns viel eher fürchten
vor dem menschengemachten
Bevölkerungswandel und schon im AFD
Grundsatzprogramm von 2016 das auch
heute noch gültig ist finden wir stellen
die ähnlich klingen da wird z.B vom
heimlichen souverän gesprochen das sei
eine kleine machtvolle politische
Führungsgruppe die vor allem ihre Macht
und ihren Wohlstand sichern wolle diese
politische Führungsgruppe verfolgt
angeblich einen großen Plan björn höcke
hatte damaligen Bundeskanzler Angela
Merkel auch schon 2015 vorgeworfen an
einer vermeintlichen Destabilisierung
Deutschlands beteiligt zu sein welche
Rolle Frau Merkel dabei spielt das kann
nur vermutet werden es gibt aber in
meinen Augen eigentlich nur zwei
Möglichkeiten die erste Möglichkeit ist
Frau Merkel hat ihren Verstand verloren
und die zweite Möglichkeit ist dass sie
in einen großen großen geopolitischen
Plan eingeweiht ist und diesen Plan
willendlich durchführt Anhängerinnen und
Anhänger des großen Austausches sprechen
unter anderem auch immer wieder von
Politikerinnen und Politikern als
Brüssler marionettenthater und von
finanzgesteuerten eu-kraken das schließt
sehr deutlich an die Erzählung von einem
sogenannten internationalen
finanzjudentum und damit auch an den
Mythus der jüdischen Weltverschwörung an
die Krake z.B wurde in der nszeit
benutzt um diese Weltverschwörung zu
symbolisieren das ist ganz klar
antisemitisch wer sowas sagt imp t unter
anderem dass Politikerinnen und
Politiker von jüdischen mächtigen
gesteuert werden aber wer gehört denn
genau zu dieser geheimen Elite oft
bleibt die Beschreibung eher schwammig
allerdings gibt's auch einzelne Personen
die ganz konkret im Visier stehen und
immer wieder genannt werden ein klares
Feindbild ist z.B George Soros das ist
ein US-amerikanischer Multimilliardär
mit jüdischer Herkunft Soros setzt sich
mit seiner open society Foundation für
eine offene Gesellschaft ein ob Trump
Orban oder Elon Musk sie alle sehen in
ihm eine Bedrohung sowohl Trump als auch
Orban beschuldigen ihn z.B gezielt
Flüchtlingsströme zu finanzieren diese
Erzählung werden auch von der extremen
Rechten immer wieder verbreitet Sorus
wird ein großer Einfluss auf die globale
Politik nachgesagt bei großen
Weltereignissen wie dem Krieg in Syrien
oder der Black lives matter Bewegung
wurde ständig behauptet dass eigentlich
Soros im Hintergrund steht und dass es
irgendwie mit dem großen Austausch oder
anderen verschwörungserzählung zu tun
hätte spätestens an der Stelle an der
Menschen und Organisationen als
vermeintlich schuldig benannt werden
wird die Gefahr durch die
verschwörungserzählung ganz deutlich das
haben wir 2011 in Norwegen gesehen daran
können sich wahrscheinlich die meisten
von euch erinnern der rechtsterrorist
anders breiwig hat bei seinem Anschlag
gezielt politische Institutionen in der
Hauptstadt Oslo angegriffen aber auch
das Sommercamp der sozialdemokratischen
Jugendorganisation breiwig wollte den
Nachwuchs der Arbeiterpartei töten weil
er die für einen angeblichen
Bevölkerungsaustausch verantwortlich
gemacht hat beim Anschlag am 22 juli
2011 ermordete er 77 Menschen auch beim
rechtsextremen Anschlag 2019 in Halle
hat die Erzählung vom großen Austausch
eine große Rolle gespielt der Täter hat
dem Feminismus die Schuld für niedrige
Geburtenraten gegeben und ganz konkret
Jüdinnen und Juden für angebliche
Masseneinwanderung verantwortlich
gemacht darum hat er erst versucht die
Synagoge in Halle am jüdischen Feiertag
jomkipur anzugreifen ein Massaker wurde
nur dadurch verhindert dass die Tür der
Synagoge standhielt am Ende erschoss er
wahlos zwei Menschen ein anderer
Anschlag hatte Muslime als Ziel in
Christchurch in Neuseeland wurden 2019
beimem Angriff auf zwei Moscheen
insgesamt 51 Menschen ermordet das
Manifest des Täters trü den Titel The
Great replacement das sind nur drei
Beispiele in den letzten Jahrzehnten
wurden hunderte Menschen getötet weil
die Täter Anhänger extremrechter
Ideologien waren und an die
verschwörungserzählung von einem
angeblichen Bevölkerungsaustausch
geglaubt haben viele von euch erinnern
sich sicher auch an Walter Lüpke der
cdupitiker wurde von Akif perinche in
seinem Buch als ein Verantwortlicher für
die um volkung benannt Walter Lüpke
wurde 2019 von einem Neonazi auf seiner
Veranda erschossen der Täter stand der
AFD nah und hat an die identitäre
Bewegung gespendet bei dem
Rechtsextremisten der dem Täter die
Waffe organisiert hat wurde perinzches
Buch gefunden Lüpkes Name war dort mit
Textmarker angestrichen okay ziehen wir
mal ein Fazit wer vom großen Austausch
spricht verbreitet eine
verschwörungserzählung die Erzählung ist
ein zerbild der Realität das Einstellung
bedient die in Teilen der Gesellschaft
verbreit sind die Behauptungen sind
nicht neu sie haben sich schon lange in
der Gesellschaft festgesetzt
Antisemitismus Frauenfeindlichkeit
verschiedene rassistische Annahmen und
feindselige Einstellung gegenüber
Muslimin und Muslimen sind in der
Bevölkerung verbreitet sehr bezeichnet
ist hier übrigens in Deutschland gibt es
eine massive Überschätzung des Anteils
von Musliminnen und Muslimen in einer
Umfrage des Meinungsforschungsinstituts
Ipsos von 2016 wurde ihr Anteil an der
Bevölkerung auf 21% geschätzt
tatsächlich sind es im Jahr 2013 20 nur
6 bis 7% die verschwörungserzählung vom
großen Austausch puzzelt verschiedene
narrative zu einem großen Bild zusammen
um eine einfache Erklärung für
komplizierte gesellschaftliche Prozesse
anzubieten was wir klar sagen wollen
einzelne Elemente vom großen Austausch
werden nicht nur von Rechtsextremisten
verbreitet aber die extreme Rechte hat
die strategische Anschlussfähigkeit
davon erkannt sie will sich damit in der
Nähe der gesellschaftlichen Mitte
positionieren und gleichzeitig die
Politik nach rechts ziehen die Erzählung
vom großen Austausch nutzt sie ganz
bewusst dafür wenn Björn höcke z.B einen
aktuellen Anschlag nutzt um vermeintlich
unvereinbare Unterschiede zwischen
Kulturen anzusprechen ist das eine
bewusste Strategie Migration und Flucht
gab es schon immer das ist die Wahrheit
mit der eine Gesellschaft umgehen muss
gegen Probleme die dadurch entstehen
können helfen keine rassistischen
verschwörungserzählungen sondern eine
Politik die das anerkennt und
realpitische Lösung findet seid ihr mit
diesem Thema auch schon in Kontakt
gekommen wie gefährlich findet ihr das
und fallen euch bestimmte
verschwörungserzählungen ein die wir
näher anschauen sollen schreibt es uns
in die Kommentare alle zwei Wochen kommt
auf dem Kanal hier ein neuer background
Check von uns abonniert hier wenn ihr
immer up to date sein
wollt